the Democratic mayor of Eagle Pass Texas
says he feels abandoned by the White
House in the wake of multiple
invitations for the president to visit
his overwhelmed Border
Town here at Eagle PS we feel abandoned
we shouldn't have to be dealing with
this this is a federal issue I have made
that invitation to President Biden our
vice president anyone from the
administration please come visit EV will
pass at the very
least wow that's a Democrat mayor this
is a record 10,000 migrants cross the
southern Border in just one 24-hour
period this week and that's not the only
record Being shattered CBP reported more
than
230,000 Encounters in August a historic
high for the month Rosa arano is a
retired border patrol officer and a
resident of Eagle Pass and she joins us
now Rosa so great to have you on so the
president won't come and visit and many
Americans will never get a chance to see
what it's like to live in Eagle past
under these emergency uh you know crisis
situation that you're in could you
explain to our viewers what it's like to
live in Eagle Pass um with this
surge okay well thank you very much for
having me Eagle Pass it's a small
community it's usually silent we usually
you know have our doors open during the
day we close up only at night but with
this border search it's really really
impacted our local community I mean
every time you make a trip anywhere from
point A to point B you encounter these
uh illegal aliens roaming around our
communities and what scares us the most
is whenever you see these groups of
young adult males uh you know walking
together in groups and then they start
approaching you for money for uh
assistance and it's gotone to the point
where you're driving around and they're
digging through trash cans and stuff
like that like that we don't feel safe
especially our elderly folks uh right
now they're on high alert they're having
to maintain their homes locked at all
times 24 hours our children most of them
are having to be driven over for point A
to point B when normally you know I live
in an area where there's a a local Eagle
Pass Junior High and an elementary
school within a one block from each side
of my home and you see the increase of
parents bringing their children over to
school you know because we don't feel
safe anymore yeah kids can't walk to
school anymore because the parents know
they have to give them a ride because
they can't they don't feel safe so when
you hear there's a lot been a lot of
media attention about what's going on in
New York because some of the migrants
are being busted and shipped or you know
given flights out to New York City and
um there's been a lot of attention here
including from some very rich residents
like the ladies from the view for
example who supported the open border
policy that Biden had but now say they
shouldn't come to New York so when
someone from Eagle Pass here's people in
New York City for example complaining
about illegal immigration what are your
thoughts on
that it's a joke I mean they're
complaining about a couple you know
hundred or 200 bodies coming over to
their large communities and we're over
here being swamped what was it like over
two three th000 in one night time and
we're stuck here with them we don't get
any sort of assistance like mayor Selena
stated we don't get assistance from the
federal government whatsoever yet these
larger communities that are complaining
and that claim to be Sanctuary cities
they're they're complaining so like I
said it's a joke we hear it and we all
just laugh about it like and of course
we're upset at the same time um going
I'm sorry go ahead going going back to
what you mentioned in regards to how
we're feeling here at the Border Town of
Eagle Pass a lot of people do not have
in mind that we have the the railroad
the international railroad that crosses
literally through the middle of our city
and it makes repeated stops throughout
different locations in these locations
include nearby elementary schools
daycare centers
churches um all sorts of residential
spots you know so it's pretty dangerous
because every time a stop is made you
see groups of illegal aliens jumping off
of the RO boox cars you know being
dispur into our community so it's very
scary a lot of people do not have that
in mind that we have that railroad
crossing right through the middle of our
city well thank you Rosa it's really
danger it's really troubling that the
president won't come see what to see
what his policies have created Rosa
thank you for giving us that Insight
appreciate it thank you I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis